we got a super chat real quick I'm gonna
throw it to you oh yeah just real quick
good
they said Trump watched Tim's rant Trump
started crackdown after last Monday I'm
a conservative and I'm excited to bring
home our troops I told you he watched it
he said it really I don't care that's
proof but the jet hasn't watched it the
reason this is funny is because Trump is
now trying to bring our soldiers back
from Afghanistan yeah and who's blocking
it the Democrats well it's not even
about that the media right they all are
dude was trying to stop it why what what
I had it I had I'm talking to a friend
of mine Lefty yeah and I said what do
you think about Donald Trump trying to
bring our troops back from Afghanistan
you know the response was huh
Trump's doing that yeah is that what the
response what do you that is what I
think they're responsible response where
I'm suing that well I mean I have to
look in a situation I mean there's
probably a good reason why our troops
are there of course okay yeah no I think
it should have been the scandal of the
freakin whatever 50 years is called the
fact that we're still in Iraq and
Afghanistan
I mean knew that we didn't need to be
there and we stayed yes oh oh all of a
sudden you've got I think Rand Paul
proposed it I think I'm not entirely
sure Tom it pulled up I think you have
you have you seen this I think you're
right I think it is Rand Paul he's
talking about people when he got people
serving there they were born after the
war started yeah that are there in a lie
apparently both parties shot him down
yep they're like now we're not we're not
we're not gonna we're not gonna bring
our troops against any nuts we make way
too much money on the war machine here's
what happens
Trump wants to bring our troops back
yeah and I'm like yeah me too yes please
awesome and what happens a story drops
in the New York Times Vladimir Putin is
is paying a bounty you owe to the
Taliban to Afghan militants to kill
American soldiers there's another one of
my one of my friends I say friends
loosely because I have you know I don't
really know them that well but they were
shoving this down my throat how could
you vote for Trump look at this
information that I have about him
knowing about them and I'm like okay
show me your information Oh
read it sure because I'm down to be
proven wrong you hear that yeah
everybody I don't care okay being proven
wrong in fact I welcome it and everybody
should be welcome to be proven wrong
yeah that's why you know you know and I
read it hold on I just want to say I
read it no proof none of it was proven
it was all like well now this is what
we're talking about so that could mean
that this happened what is this an
anonymous source experts say it's like
okay well actually give me the experts
because I'd like there I want to read
what they're saying don't just tell me
an expert told you and that's the way it
is now no no no you know what you know
what it's true oh it is
it absolutely is tired well Tim since
Tim told I said it's true listen listen
to him yeah the New York Times the paper
of record the gray lady has told us this
is happening yeah for now I don't need
evidence if they said it therefore if it
is true that that that Trump knew our
soldiers are in danger we must
immediately bring back every single
soldier from that country because their
lives are in danger and what is Trump do
he says we should bring these people
home well he's been fight no no no I
know well first off it first off he said
I was never briefed on this right so he
and him bringing the troops trying to
bring the troops home had nothing to do
with that well the joke just trying to
end the war I know I get I get what
you're saying I just wanted to say that
if the argument is that Putin is
offering money and our troops are in
harm's way guess we got to bring them
all back yeah man we can't believe you
don't want you troops to be in danger do
you right and you and you know Trump's
not there for them we better bring our
soldiers home from Afghanistan newsflash
they were in danger before Putin even at
presumably did anything they're in a war
zone because we put them there so let's
get him out of there I'm okay with that
canna stan was so dumb you know you know
you know why I'm in Iraq and Afghanistan
surround Iran yep
John Bolten that guy who I love man The
Onion read this article oh goodness
it's a picture of John Bolton like this
he's like gasping he's holding a gunshot
wound and it says John Bolton breaks
into Oval Office screaming that he'd
been shot by Iran
yeah that that dude and now and now it's
no surprise he is ragging on Trump he's
trying to sell a book yeah
these people love war man yeah yeah it's
a war monger it's war is literally war
is money it keeps things a churning baby
dude it keeps people united in some
extent I mean well you know you know who
I think I think Trump has really
activated a lot of people in such a
tremendous way tremendous I never
tremendous the best I cannot believe
that I have people friends of mine
actually going well maybe we do need
soldiers in Afghanistan
oh man the left is meaningless it just
doesn't even make sense anymore how is
it we got this guy you're super Chet
he's a conservative he's excited to
bring our troops home and I'm like hear
hear yes what yep I don't get it at all
the neocon like all-out war yeah it's
like everyone you know this is this is
what I the more I'm looking into the
political realm the the issues never
really with the presidency it's the it's
the House and the Senate
they're pushing their propaganda
machines they're the ones who are really
pulling the strings of what is going on
in this planet yeah or I'm sorry the
country yeah it's insane
it's it's an it's a it's a crony
establishment absolutely and this is
like Trump is flipping the heat went in
and flip the table over and he said haha
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go bring our
troops on you know what they said about
Trump in like these leaked emails from
the Democrats they wanted to prop Trump
up as a Pied Piper candidate mm-hmm
because they thought if they made Trump
the front-runner hillary was guaranteed
to win right little did they know little
do they know he actually had plans for
this country and cares about it he'd
been talking about it for a long time
yeah that's that's it he loves America
and it's like you know what I see a lot
of anti America going on right now and
it pisses me off I see friends of mine
on Facebook I'm calling him out I don't
care anymore like I'm losing friends
left and right you know what you're not
even my friend if you've lost to no
friends think about anybody would say
that thank you Tim you're absolutely
right you know it's like there is
nothing wrong with being proud of this
country nothing at all and
I'm proud of this country you know what
you need in this country that made me
who I am and I love Who I am there's
nothing wrong with that either here's
what I'm gonna do here here
Tim cast IRL is announcing a special
all-expenses-paid vacation to a select
list of countries for any person who
prescribes to leftist ideology yes
possibly a second world country one way
to know I offered this to people before
oh yeah yeah I got one arguing with a
dude yeah no I go see what it's like
outside of this this amazing guy tree
where would you like to go yeah where
anywhere with a conversation and I said
I will get you a round-trip ticket
I'll go tell but you must sign a waiver
that I am NOT responsible if you die
thing that happens right yeah nothing I
can't be able responsive US is you're
going of your own volition and oh you
know it all falls a card on you don't ya
do I need Sookie I had one person ask do
I need security I'm like I don't know
are you do you do you know what it's
like to to think I think I might need
security in this place because you're
you're fearful of your life every single
day yeah maybe that's what I should do I
should turn a nonprofit that just buys
plane tickets for the far-left to go to
like Morocco and yep maybe in Iran
Afghanistan mm-hmm Rudo monami plus yes
extra bag of pretzels that's right they
don't give peanuts anymore no they don't
have allergies but you will I will
guarantee you know what I will do I will
pay for your hotel but you nice one you
picked the country so well I mean
relative that's so so look you know but
I'll put it this way I went to Sweden
and you've been a Sweden and I went to
the bad areas of Sweden
he's beautiful yeah even the better is
there there's problems is great there's
a viral video recently of a grenade
attack some locals went to the cops and
so the gang they pull up a throw a
grenade onto their patio then you close
up yeah there's problems man
no there's problems everywhere right so
that well there's a problems in America
like I'll admit that yeah I'm not saying
that the police don't need reform that
and that's that you
my like might be one of my friends is
one of my friends like he's a good buddy
mine I we kind of had a like slight
argument and he was just saying about
like you know how can you be proud of a
country that like all this stuff needs
to happen I was like well I never said
that all those things shouldn't happen
like sure we do need some reforms right
certain things need to happen we can get
better but we also went from a slavery
based economy to now abolishing it
because of the Constitution that we made
you know and now we've we've come a long
way and it's like let's not destroy it
all let's keep moving and progressing
forward that's you know it's like we can
still be happy and proud of the progress
that we've made like I'm not gonna
forget that progress no way I'm not
gonna start treating people differently
because of the color of their skin no
they want absolutely I will never do
that ever that is that is one thing I
won't do I cannot do it and and you know
what I've seen racism in my life and
every single time that it's ever shown
its ugly face in front of me I've said
something I've quit my job
I've lost friends I've kicked people out
of my parents house because they were
just talking racist stuff and I kicked
them out of the house it's like I will I
will always speak up for it you know
it's funny what that almost sounds woke
it almost sounds well except for the
Soviet except for the fact that when you
understand what you're really saying
mm-hmm
they've changed the definition of the
word racism hmm so they're talking about
you know my dad was waving an American
flag
so I said get out of my house you're not
welcome at my birthday party which is
like not racism no I'm exaggerating mind
you but it's like it's it's things like
this they're like America itself is
white supremacy that's ridiculous I know
that's exactly that's not true it's so
it's so it's so insane it's it's it's
you know it's the funny thing the
funniest thing about this is is that the
fact that white people and you know are
on both sides either not woke or woke a
red belt Asian people
some are woke some are red pill you know
black people some are wokes on my red
belt that proves it's not a race thing
it disproves their racial rights that's
why they really
really don't like like black
conservatives that's true or Asian
conservatives or Latino conservatives
they really don't because it really
starts to hurt their ideas well why do
you think when they when the hodgetwins
posted my video of me it got deleted
boom delete it
Terrance Williams bomb deleted they
don't want that being shown around
basket it's like well no wonder yeah for
those are listening is a video of Adam
talking about voting for Trump and
Facebook nuke did after 2.4 million
views yep it's gone yep it's gone man
it's really it's really going around on
Twitter but it's like all I'm saying is
I'm thinking logically I'm doing the
research myself which I suggest to
everybody do your own research and
thoroughly do your research don't just
read the title of the article that's
what that's what all these people do
they're like oh this article proves it
I'm gonna just pass it along and I'm
like okay I'll read this article that
you say read it and I'm like reading it
I'm like okay so this it's it's an
opinion piece why are you giving me an
opinion one of the best opinion pieces
I've read lately was that all News has
become opinion there's no point there's
no line separating though the truth a
Twitter page and the news page any very
mm-hmm so I was working for fusion there
was this big story that that happened
for internet-based individuals Ellen Pao
the CEO of Reddit had resigned and a
story came out from the New York Times
that said CEO you know interim CEO Ellen
Pao resigns from reddit and it was like
a hundred words you know the the board
announced that she'll be stepping down
they would find a replacement in the
coming weeks
Ellen Powell was serving as well habla
how's it simple straight forward the
next day news that URL that same link
had been rewritten to an opinion piece
about sexism in Silicon Valley the title
became something like Silicon Valley
Bros to you know you know women in the
workplace 0 or some art you know
feminist Z or something like that and
then it was giving this opinion and
analysis about the problems of women and
tack and everything like that the reason
why this was such a big story for me at
the time is that they changed the link
so if you let's say you post a link to a
story oh yeah say I shared the original
post let's say
let's say you share the original story
yeah and you're like wow look at this
breaking news yeah and the next day they
change it to say a bunch of things like
they love Nazis right and then people
are gonna be like whoa Adam what are you
sure are you right
so when they switched it to a feminist
article mm-hmm
all of a sudden you had people who
probably shared the breaking news now
inadvertently having shared a feminist
article right that realizes very sneaky
and they they didn't correction I didn't
put an update no and so at fusion
I said I'm like in the slack chat and
I'm like whoa dude this is huge it's
huge because this story was the number
three and number five most uploaded post
of all time for reddit and read history
cow and they changed the story
disqualifying it and the moderators
deleted it so record breaking posts got
deleted from reddit because of the the
unethical activities of the New York
Times and so when I started working on
putting something together did you know
the people at fusion told me what don't
report this story what because then
we'll get called out for it too
and I said are you implying that you do
that are you telling me right now that
our company will will change articles
without putting corrections or notes
well everybody does this oh yeah I mean
the guy who said it now works for the
New York Times are you serious
water percent oh my gosh yep okay
welcome to modern journalism there's
another story going around and I'm
mostly gonna stay out of it okay because
there there are some woke journalists
that I think are cordial enough and I'm
they're nice to me so I give them
respect 100 percent so I'm not gonna get
involved in dragging them if I think
they're saying if they're saying
something very very dumb we're lying
I'll definitely call them out but
there's a few people who typically just
report non political news but our super
woke and now there's this big thing
happening and I'm watching I'm watching
the drama develop and and these news
outlets are all writing about each other
again because like some journalists you
know did a story and then someone got
mad and now they're writing another zark
drama and in different journalists
organizations and I'm sitting here just
like are you writing about each other
again did you see the story from the
Washington Post where they wrote about
Halloween party two years ago where a
random
no one ever heard of who's not a public
figure was wearing blackface no that's
that's that story that's it that's it
that's that's it everyone's like who's
this woman they ruined her life who is
she and why is white why is she
newsworthy why is this news seriously
because they just click worthy because
people get emotionally compromised and
so they trigger those emotions thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you